Hello world. It's the Raj and
have you ever played doom before?
It's a classic shooter and we're going
to use a technique called the actor
critic to train an AI to beat
the game on its own deep minds,
deep Q network,
the same algorithm that beats so many
different games made history and brought
our l back into the limelight.
Let's just take a second to appreciate
how mind blowing the results it achieved.
We're starting with no
knowledge on what winning means.
It was able to explore the environment
and eventually master the game.
Think about putting yourself
in that same situation.
It'd be like asking you to play a game
without a rule book or an end goal and
saying keep playing until you win.
Oh and the possible results states you
could reach with a series of actions is
infinite, I. E. A continuous
observation space.
Only young Macoun could do
that despite this scenario.
Deep Q was able to converge really quickly
on this seemingly impossible task by
maintaining and slowly
updating action value pairs.
But what happens when we have an infinite
input space and an infinite output
space? Well, deep Q is no longer
an effective algorithm, but wait,
isn't it completely independent of the
structure of the environment actions
while it was independent
of what the actions were,
but it was fundamentally premise on having
a finite output space. Think about it.
The prediction looks to assign a score
to each possible action at each time step
given the current environment state
and just uses the action that had the
highest score.
Basically it reduced the problem of
our l two assigning scores to actions,
but how could this be possible if
we have an infinite input space,
we basically need an infinitely large
table to keep track of all the Q values.
Think of this task this way.
Not only are we being given a game
without instructions about the game has a
controller with infinite buttons on it.
That'd be a terrible controller, right?
Almost as bad as the
playstation mouse was,
deep queue is restricted to
a finite number of actions
and that's because of the
way the model is structured.
We've got to be able to iterate at each
time step to update how our position on
a particular action has changed.
That's why we're having the model
predict Q values rather than directly
predicting what action to take.
If we had the ladder,
we'd have no clue on how to update
the model to take into account that
prediction and what reward we'd
receive for future predictions.
So the issue stems from the fact that
it seems like our model has to output a
tabulated table of the rewards
associated with all the possible actions.
But here's an idea. What if instead
we split the model into two?
What if we had two separate models,
one that outputs the desired action and
the continuous space and another taking
in an action as input to produce Q
values that seems like it could work.
And guess what?
It's exactly the idea behind the actor
critic model or actor critic methods are
premised on having two models.
And this theme of having multiple neural
nets interacting seems to be getting
more popular,
not just in reinforcement learning,
but in supervised learning as well.
Like in the case of generative
adversarial networks and variational auto
encoders,
seriously,
almost everyone's slapped the word Gan
on their paper at nips and called it a
day. But that's a side note. The
actor critic model has two components,
an actor and a critic.
The actor takes in the current environment
state and determines the best action
to take.
From there the critic plays the evaluation
role by taking in the environment,
state and action and we're turning a
score that represents how good the action
is for the state.
One way to think about this
is as a playground with a
child being the actor and
her parent being the critic.
The kid is running around and exploring
all the possible options in this
environment. They could slide down
a slide, take a ride on a swing,
pull grass from the ground and eat it.
The parent's job is to watch the kid
and either criticize or compliment them
based on what they did. Taking the
environment into account. Actor,
critic methods are advantageous to
policy gradient methods as well.
Let's go into a bit more detail
of how actor critic works.
But first I want to take a
second to explain the chain
rule because it's used in
this method and it's just really
important in machine learning in general,
like say in the case of
backpropagation for neural networks,
the chain rule is a rule that comes
from calculus that helps us compute the
derivative of a composite function
that is a function of functions.
The idea is that you derive the outer
function and derive the inner function and
multiplied them together and that'll
give you the derivative of the whole
composite function.
And it's a recursive rule.
So it applies for as many
nested functions there are,
the derivative of the s is the slope of
the tangent line at a point on the curve
of a function. It's a way to
represent the rate of change,
meaning the amount by which a
function is changing at a given point.
The chain rule will help us update the
parameters of our actor critic model.
So in our system where the output of
one network feeds into the input of the
other, updating the parameters of the
feeding network will shake up its output,
which will then propagate
and be multiplied by any
further changes through the
end of the pipeline.
When we implement our model,
note that it has the same exact
task that deep Q would have,
except we have two separate modules.
We start by defining the actor model.
Given the current state of the environment
determined the best action to take
and since the task is given numeric data,
there's no need to involve any
complex layers in our network.
Just fully connected once.
So the actor model is just a series of
fully connected layers that match from
the environment observation to a
point in the environment space.
We're going to return a reference
to the input layer as well,
and I'll explain why in a second,
but how are we going to determine
the best action to take?
The Q scores are now calculated
separately in the critic network.
We're going to use an optimization
strategy called gradient ascent.
This means attempting to reach a global
maximum by moving incrementally in the
steepest direction of an incline and the
way we get the direction to move is by
using the chain rule to
compute derivatives I. E.
Gradients of the weights of our network.
What change in parameters for our
actor model would result in the largest
increase in the Q value which would
be predicted by the critic model.
Since the output of the actor model is
the action and the critic evaluates based
on an environment state action pair,
we can see that the chain
rule helps us do this.
Changing the parameters of the actor will
change the eventual Q value using the
output of the actor network as our
middle link for our critic network.
We're faced with the opposite issue.
The network is a bit more complicated,
but training is straightforward.
The critic must take both the environment,
state and action as inputs
and calculate a valuation.
We use a series of fully connected
layers with the layer in the middle that
merges the two before combining
into the final Q value prediction.
We use one extra fully connected
layer on the environment.
State input as compared to the action
will hold onto references of both the
inputs,
states and action since we don't need
to use them and doing updates for the
actor network. The output queue with
respect to the action weights I. E.
The gradient is directly
called in the training code.
Since we have two training methods,
we separate the code
into different functions.
We're training on the state action pair
and using the critic model to predict
the future reward rather than the actor.
The actor just needs to be called with
the actions and states we encounter and
our prediction could just iterate
through a trial called predict.
Remember and train the agent.
Notice how our doom bought after training
for about 20 hours on a single CPU is
able to kill monsters and navigate
successfully through the environment.
A lack of boss. All right,
three things to remember here.
Actor critic methods work well when we
have both an infinite input space and
infinite output space.
In an actor critic model,
the actor takes in the
current environment,
states and determines
the best action to take.
The critic plays the evaluation role
by taking in the environment states and
action and returning an action score.
And actor critic methods tend to require
much less training time and policy
gradient methods. Last week's
coding challenge winner. He's fine.
He trained an AI to play tic tac toe
using the policy gradients strategy and
he's documentation makes it
easy for you to reuse his code.
Great Work Wizard of the week.
And the runner up is [inaudible] Kumar
who use a convolutional network and cue
learning to have an AI learn how to play
flappy birds.
Really Clever Algorithm.
This week's challenge is to generate
some music using deep learning.
So the challenge is to either create a
model that generates music or generate
music from one of the existing models
that we talked about here today.
Send me your finished track and or tracks
to my Twitter handle at Taryn southern.
You can upload it to any
site that you prefer. Um,
just please don't include viruses and,
uh,
and I will pick my favorite and I will
actually write lyrics and vocals to that.
Karen is going to write lyrics for
this song. She's going to work with it,
so definitely submit
it to her via Twitter.
And I'll also announce the two top
entries next week in next week's video.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos. And I think we got to go.
We've got to go make some AI music.
It's true. So thanks for watching.